“As an online discussion grows longer, the
probability of a comparison involving Nazis
or Hitler approaches one.”
– Mike Godwin
Coined in 1990 by author and attorney Mike
Godwin, Godwin’s Law was originally, to
quote Godwin “a project in memetic engineering”,
partially inspired by a 1980s article he read
in Whole Earth Review in which they discuss
the power of memes to spread ideas.
(And if you’re wondering, the word meme
was originally coined in 1976 by biologist
Richard Dawkins to describe the way ideas
and values propagate in a similar manner to
genes and, in some cases, viruses.
For more on this see: Where the Word Meme
Comes From)
Godwin noted that “Through most of the 1980s,
I’d been a hobbyist using computer ‘bulletin-board
systems’ that connected small local communities
by telephone lines.
I couldn’t help but notice how often comparisons
to Hitler or Nazis came up in heated exchanges,
usually as a kind of rhetorical hammer to
express rage or contempt for one’s opponent.
Once I was back in school to study law, I
leveraged my student status to get a free
Internet-based computer account.
With access to the global Internet came still
more hyperbolic Hitler and Nazi comparisons.”
These sorts of flippant comparisons to Hitler,
Nazism and the Holocaust troubled Godwin,
particularly after reading Surviving in Auschwitz,
by Primo Levi.
He noted of the work, “I had… seen many
of the photos of the death camps, with their
emaciated bodies stacked like cordwood and
the haunted, piercing eyes of the skeletal
inmates who survived.
But Levi’s writings brought the experience
home to me—they helped me understand better
what the experience must have been like for
prisoners.”
Thus, he “half-seriously and half-whimsically”
decided to create a counter meme to combat
the Hitler-meme tendency.
Essentially, he “wanted to hint that most
people who brought Nazis into a debate about,
say, New York Gov. Andrew Cuomo’s views
on gun control weren’t being thoughtful
and independent.
Instead, they were acting just as predictably,
and unconsciously, as a log rolling down a
hill.”
The solution to the problem, he thought, was
“to build a counter-meme designed to make
discussion participants see how they are acting
as vectors to a particularly silly and offensive
meme…and perhaps to curtail the glib Nazi
comparisons.”
The result of all this contemplation was the
following “law”:
As a Usenet discussion grows longer, the probability
of a comparison involving Nazis or Hitler
approaches one.
To give his new meme that all important air
of authority, Godwin dubbed it Godwin’s
Law of Nazi Analogies, before posting it in
any online discussions he came across that
invoked Hitler or the Nazis.
It wasn’t long before other users were citing
his law as well, and the meme spread from
there.
So the idea spread, but did it actually change
anything?
While hard data is not available one way or
the other on the frequency of Hitler citing
in early online discussions pre and post Godwin’s
Law, in a 1994 article about his experiment,
Godwin noted that, at least in his opinion,
following the introduction of his law instances
of Hitler comparisons seemed to have noticeably
dropped on the discussion boards he frequented.
Thus, he considered it a success.
All this said, while today Godwin’s law
is often invoked in support of the notion
that as soon as one makes such a Nazi comparison
in a debate, said individual has officially
lost the argument, Godwin himself doesn’t
hold to this.
He notes that, in his opinion, it’s perfectly
fine to compare some viewpoint to Hitler and
the Nazis, particularly when discussing political
ideologies, provided it’s done in a thoughtful,
intelligent manner, unlike the flippant, irrational
comparisons that are far more common.
He stated of this, “The best way to prevent
future holocausts, I believe, is not to forbear
from Holocaust comparisons; instead, it’s
to make sure that those comparisons are meaningful
and substantive.”
It should also be noted here that Godwin was
not the first to lament Hitler and the Nazis
being invoked in attempts to disprove someone’s
viewpoint or position.
In 1951, a mere six years after Hitler’s
death, the phenomenon of “Reductio ad Hitlerum”
was given a name by German philosopher Leo
Strauss.
He described this in Natural Right and History,
In following this movement towards its end
we shall inevitably reach a point beyond which
the scene is darkened by the shadow of Hitler.
Unfortunately, it does not go without saying
that in our examination we must avoid the
fallacy that in the last decades has frequently
been used as a substitute for the reductio
ad absurdum: the reductio ad Hitlerum.
A view is not refuted by the fact that it
happens to have been shared by Hitler.
Another popular eponymous law frequently evoked
online that we’ve talked about before is,
Cunningham’s Law, states: “The best way
to get the right answer on the Internet is
not to ask a question, but to post the wrong
answer.”
Along with coining this famous rule of the
internet, the man behind the law, Ward Cunnigham
invented the Wiki, paving the way for sites
like Wikipedia.
The word “wiki” itself is Hawaiian for
“quick”.
(Incidentally, it’s also technically pronounced
we-key, not wick-ey, though given that pretty
much everyone mispronounces it, Cunningham
and others have long stopped correcting people,
ironically enough.)